il reste
la vallée chacun
ap ap
[Musique]
jaloux
pas grave
pour calmer l'opposition demandait sur
la gêne t parce qu'on avait
g
geo
là
elle porte une ombre
[Musique]
ouais
infiniment etc au profit d'agents en
civils allemands s'inquiètent justement
tout seul dans la bagnole je l'avais
repéré le long du rond point n'était pas
l'heure c'est là bas qu'on va refaire
l'image après qu il y avait tout le
monde l'a annoncé pas fait sinon je peux
leur peuple est recouvert en montant le
s y remonte si tu es là tu me viennent
voter comme ça look tué le dernier au
cours s'est arrêté près de 20 de ce rond
point là je pense c'est dernier où s'est
arrêté où les pulsions de nous on s'est
garés sur le côté là on vient de la rue
albert camus entrailles
entre l'avenue ferment châtelain et
l'avenue albert camus oui on est certes
une heure et au bouddha ou là c'est
comme ça c'est ça là on est là parce que
c'était l'ambition canon vient de haut
et là ont déçu par la bbc annonce à
lasser au bout
alors pardon alors que j'étais là bas
à tabac et après la gauche ouais ça à
gauche et on a fait deux fois gauche que
les accroître
jamais deux fois là si tu vois tout
droite à un rond point
ouais c'est pas celui là est alors après
non et on vient de la gauche donc
première à gauche du front avenue albert
camus et tu remontes
bon ça marche bon allez bon courage à
leurs aspirations
les peu plus journée ce canton est
arrivé
deux caméras là c'est bon on n'est pas
si nombreux alors pour info moi je suis
sur la gauche tu as une école école le
trou vignon du village officiers
sapeurs-pompiers qui sont tous connus je
pense qu'on va aller là-bas
parce que j'ai pas vu la voiture qui
agiront bleus passaient là il est allé
là bas et a entraîné des officiers 14 de
l'école donc c'est à quoi 100 mètres sur
la gauche que tu vois les éclairages
rang c'est là que je pense que ma
convalescence
je pense qu'il me guider un j'espère
qu'au l'armée
[Musique]
la photo là non mais pour les potes
c'est patrice perron compagnies qui sont
pas là si de loin et après matière de
gratter en photo ci sont de prendre peur
ça fait toujours gagner
[Musique]
rien à paris
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
je sais
honneur
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît donc c'est vous baissez
vous s'il vous plaît
non
m
[Musique]
mais je veux commencer
bleu
[Musique]
la période
m
[Musique]
l'accord passé
ouais
or pour chats
très beau débat sur place j'ai pris le
boîtier comme celui-ci c'est mm et aux
600 mm je vois de loin les mecs
ambulants diseurs si tu diffères travail
sur le toit donc je sens que tu peux
rajouter des photos un temps
m
d'ici peu
je m'attendais
elle
[Musique]
non
elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mapa probable
comment aller
on a perdu
[Musique]
suite
sa chair
[Musique]
aof hi media
ça rase gratis
peur
[Rires]
eh oui
[Musique]
kg
m
[Musique]
allez un peu creux
m
[Musique]
ses côtés
je
[Musique]
pourquoi
il
[Musique]
ouais autour de benzema aux musiciens